[Music]
this fall the seventh arena yes the
seventh one in southern nevada will open
up their doors
sports director chris matthews joining
us from henderson where workers are
trying to meet a february opening for
the dollar loan center hi chris
how you doing guys good evening
everybody i'll tell you what they're
calling this thing the mini t-mobile now
the
man whose company name will shine on the
side of this arena and the president of
the vegas golden knights taking us on an
exclusive tour of the henderson facility
this 84 million dollar facility is built
for hockey but it will be home to many
other events like indoor football and
basketball it's a mini t-mobile it's
going to be a gathering place the
epicenter really for henderson mayor
deborah marsh will deliver her next
state of the city address inside this
venue and there will be concerts for
sure it's an ideal venue for concerts
chuck and i share share a common
interest in classic rock so i would love
to see zz top and i can't wait to see
great bands like the foo fighters here
and and things like that
we're going to do our best to get the
best concerts here
all right we'll see the best concerts
here classic rock how about some country
bill foley likes country you'll see a
lot of concerts inside there and a lot
of basketball the first sporting event
inside the dollar loan center will be
the big west basketball championships
for both the men and the women that's
going to be coming up on march 8. he's